[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le Français Alain calma a séduit tous
les spectateurs au cours des
championnats d'Europe de patinage
artistiques qui se sont déroulés cette
année à Budapest en l'absence du
tchécoslovaque divine Calman avait aucun
concurrent à sa mesure
et au cours de son exhibition tentant
figure libre configure imposées jamais
personne n'a douté de son succès final
le couple allemand marie-caillous Hans
Bandler n'a pas eu plus de difficultés
que le Français Alain calma pour
remporter cette année encore le titre de
champion d'Europe
[Musique]
Marika et Hans ont 41 ans AE2 ils ont
tout l'avenir devant eux et la
perspective de faire fortune dans les
rangs professionnels on leur a fait un
pont d'or mais pour le moment il refuse
[Musique]
ils veulent être champion olympique
après cela on verra
[Musique]
s'il continue de patiner avec cet
aisance nul doute qu'il réussiront dans
leurs entreprises en attendant ils ne
sont pas loin de la perfection
[Musique]
une perfection qui leur vaut une
médaille d'or
Alain calma lui aussi ajoute une
médaille à sa collection et ça ne fait
que commencer
[Musique]
le catch qui est en quelque sorte un
cocktail de lutte et de comédie tout à
la fois continue de faire les beaux
soirs des spectateurs parisiens ceux en
tout cas qui aiment les émotions fortes
de la sarthèse et renter sur ce point de
les ont pas déçu
Zavatta est venu là pour chercher des
idées entre clown n'est-ce pas
ne nous appelons pas
vous allez voir ce que vous allez voir
c'est comme cela que l'on fait le pied
sur un RIB
action Hunter martyrise son adversaire
on sent pour l'air même dans la salle
la sarthèse se prend pour Tarzan ma
parole
il est vrai qu'il faut tous les talents
pour faire du catch
et finalement comme il faut bien que
tous la finisse la sarthèse gagne ce
combat ce sera pour Hunter la prochaine
fois
[Applaudissements]
il est encore rare de trouver des usines
implantées en pleine nature pourtant ce
spectacle existe maintenant pourquoi
parce que des villes de province ont su
les accueillir Pau est un exemple
caractéristique d'une cité en expansion
les facteurs de son développement l'AC
évidemment car cette richesse naturelle
a permis la naissance d'un complexe
industriel unique en France ce sont des
milliers d'emplois qui furent créés dans
cette zone quelque peu déshérités
[Musique]
mais lac n'explique pas l'évolution
démographique de Pau jusqu'à Mourenx une
ville a été créée pour accueillir les
employés du complexe alors quels sont
les motifs qui ont permis à peau de
passer en moins de 10 ans de 40 à 60000
habitants cette ville a joué
essentiellement sur deux tableaux et là
immédiatement installé un institut de
droit des collèges de lettres et de
sciences d'un des locaux provisoires
mais un vaste ensemble universitaire se
prépare
[Musique]
l'enseignement secondaire possède des
locaux pour près de 5000 lycéens
l'enseignement primaire pour plus de
8000 écoliers et un effort tout
particulier a été réalisé en faveur du
technique un lycée prépare les
techniciens et les ouvriers spécialisés
que les industriels recherchent
enfin un centre d'apprentissage féminin
complète l'équipement scolaire
la ville peut également offrir de
nombreux loisirs indispensables élément
pour fixer les cadres éloignés de la
capitale
[Musique]
sur la construction et l'urbanisme la
ville qui avait la forme d'un V dont le
centre était vide a établi un plan
d'urbanisme dans lequel s'intègre la
construction des facultés et celle des
logements
[Musique]
la possibilité de trouver un logement
est indéfacteurs essentiels qui
déterminent le choix d'une localisation
industrielle ce ne sont pas des
industries lourdes comme celles de lac
que la ville veut attirer mais des
industries complémentaires petites
unités d'une centaine d'emplois chacune
déjà plusieurs industriels se sont
établies dans la ville une fabrique de
chaussures une
usine de matérielle magnétique d'autres
encore pour orienter cette expansion une
zone industrielle est en voie de
création sur le territoire d'une commune
voisine d'ores et déjà l'activité
commerciale et la preuve que peau a
gagné son pari l'expansion rapide de Pau
et le résultat des efforts et des
initiatives d'une ville qui avec raison
sur l'avenir
la reine Elizabeth est le duc
d'Édimbourg ont reçu des cadeaux qui ont
peu de chances de les suivre à
Buckingham Palace
mais la souveraine n'était pas au bout
de ses surprises à l'heure du thé elle
s'est vu offrir comme un tout visiteur
de qualité le traditionnel yagona à base
de plantes et de racines d'arbres
qu'elle a reçu et bu avec une
impassibilité aussi protocolaire que
britannique
c'est la première fois qu'un souverain
britannique visite les Fidji dont
l'accueil aura été particulièrement
chaleureux
[Applaudissements]
dans les steppes de l'Île-de-France on
les a vu rodés à la tombée du jour
la prudence la plus élémentaire impose
de sortir en groupe et en armes
[Musique]
dans l'épaisseur des fourrés on laissa à
l'affût dès que vient la nuit les
demeures isolés se transforment en
autant de forts Chabrol dont les
occupants sont décidés à lutter jusqu'à
la dernière chevrotine
[Musique]
soucieux de vérifier le bien fondé de
certaines affirmations éminemment
troublantes nos reporters à leur tour se
sont mis en chasse
dardé de téléobjectifs on peut être
courageux sans être téméraire ils se
sont lancés sur la trace des animaux
fabuleux l'émotion les guettaient au
détour d'un sentier là la bête
malheureusement elle n'avait pas l'air
tellement sous-alimenté
pendant un bref instant ils ont cru
toucher au but
c'est pour la chasse aux loups
vraiment l'homme est plus encore la
femme est un loup pour l'homme
mais le premier souci d'un reporter est
de rentrer à tout prix avec une histoire
mais c'était une vieille une trêve
vieille histoire d'ailleurs déjà édité à
laquelle personne ne croit plus depuis
longtemps
nos reporters qui tenait à garder leur
place ont finalement trouvé un loup et
d'ailleurs ils ne furent pas les seuls
un vrai loup il est en résidence forcée
en plein Paris au Jardin des Plantes
[Musique]